hey everybody it's Mike from orderflows
and in this video I'm going to talk
about a Delta anomaly that we call the
price action Divergence in orderflow now
before I jump in y if you like my videos
be sure to hit the Subscribe button so
you'll be notified when I post a new
video and if you enjoy um or get the
value out of these videos be sure to hit
that like button you know that sort of
what keeps me gives me that incentive to
keep making videos for you guys so what
is a price action Divergence well it
refers to a situation where price moves
in the opposite direction a technical
indicator and in this case um it's Delta
right Delta is the difference between
the aggressive buyers and the aggressive
sellers in a bar right that is your
indicator and there's couple ways you
can look at this now you know when
people think of Divergence they think um
in in terms of let me describe it as two
types of divergences you have regular
Divergence and you have what I call
Hidden Divergence and regular Divergence
is something that people always look for
as a potential Trend reversal but a
hidden Divergence is more of a potential
Trend continuation and what that means
is you know if if you see this happening
in the order flow it's it's a nice sign
of um continuation and what that means
is right now just go back to what Delta
is Right Delta is a net difference
between aggressive buyers and aggressive
sellers in a bar and generally speaking
right green candles candles that close
higher than where they they open you
have net aggressive buying right because
that's what moves the market higher is
people buy the offer take out the next
offer take out the next offer or if the
Market's going down people sell into the
bid right that's the aggressive seller
selling to the passive buyer and driving
the price down and you often see you
know as green candle got positive Delta
green candle positive Delta green candle
positive Delta green candle positive
Delta just as you see you know red
candle negative Delta red candle
negative Delta but there's going to be
instances where you where it diverges
right you've got the green candle with
negative Delta green candle with
negative Delta well how you know you're
probably
wondering and this is where people get
uh confused often times in order flow is
well you know I I thought you know if
the Market's going up you have
aggressive
buyers so why would you have negative
Delta well sort of the reason that you
have negative Delta is because
in the bar at one point there was very
strong aggressive selling okay so for
example on this bar that we have right
here at at you know just before 9:00
today it's got negative Delta of
20 okay well what's causing it well you
have aggressive sellers selling in this
bar right we had just made this little
swing High Market's coming down got
aggressive sellers are in control of
this
bar and you got strong NE I say strong
you got negative Delta of or sorry M
Delta ofus 236 in the bar that was your
strongest negative Delta this bar
finished at minus 20 so what that means
is early in this bar you see the selling
a balance of minus of uh 1245 against
308 so there were strong sellers
aggressive sellers early in this bar and
we finished at only minus 20 and we
turned up so again now this is a Time
based
chart and it's based on you know when
the that time period ends this is a 5
minute chart so the bar ends after 5
minutes and at this point what was
taking place was aggressive buyers were
coming in late in this bar and we moving
it higher because the aggressive sellers
were probably done selling at this point
okay that's why it actually went from
minus 236 Delta to only minus 20 so it
gained a lot back then obviously we had
the jolts numbers today um that came out
and you got that big one that big bar
there um but I'll give you a better
example okay let's go back to yesterday
this is in the bonds um yesterday was
the uh 3rd of September okay because you
know we had a nice rally in the bonds
from basically 7:30 all the way up until
about uh you know
9:00 we rallied from 123 above to almost
124 what was that high uh 21 so you know
a strong rally a point and a half over a
point and a half Point 3/4 and on this
move up okay so you got you know your
swing low here here you got your red
candle negative Delta then positive
Delta green candle positive green candle
positive green candle positive green
candle positive green candle and on this
move up you know just to give you an
idea how strong this move was you know
you got Delta increasing literally in
every single bar 328 340
1,348 2100 that's what you expect to see
okay now again you get some selling
coming in here 755 bar negative Delta
then positive again positive again
positive again growing growing growing
218 462 um 1067 then you get this bar
here negative Delta right minus
42 okay again look at this bar at one
point the Delta was - 796 which is quite
strong was considering that you're
looking at these other Deltas this is
1,000 but this is just 462 218 you know
1, 340
328 so 796 close to 800 is is quite of
kind of strong but it came all the way
back from - 796 to just minus 42 to end
at
-42 okay then we continue up um and we
get another green candle strong negative
Delta ofus
977 okay DOI candle DOI candle negative
deltas and actually what's taking place
here is you see - 42 - 977 - 1599 - 2933
so negative Delta is actually growing so
you have a lot of aggressive selling
taking place here right and this is
strong selling I mean 3,000
4,500 55,000 so you know over 5 half
th000 negative Delta just in these three
bars here and even this bar another um
you know 688 so you know likeus 5,000 in
the Delta over these four bars the
Market's not going down so what's that
telling you well you know you got very
strong selling taking place that's not
pushing this Market lower and if it's
not going to push this Market
lower absorption is taking place right
it's not just you just see the strong
negative
Delta and immediately think this
Market's going to come
off because if it doesn't you have
absorption taking place someone is there
absorbing all that aggressive selling
imagine the Delta is minus 2900 it's a
very strong Delta the volume for the bar
is
8,51 and the Delta is- 2933 so you know
30 36% of the bar is is negative Delta
of the bar's
volume it's not enough to push it down
sort of a clue earlier was this little
DOI bar here where you had again nice
strong negative Delta that was being
absorbed all that aggressive selling was
being
absorbed right and you you can just
see what happens is this Market once
that just like here once that burst of
aggressive selling is
over the aggressive buying takes over
once that burst of aggressive selling
stops in here aggressive buying takes
over right and we end up going to new
highs and even here you got another bar
strong negative Delta - 985 it's a green
candle right cuz really what's taking
place if you look at the bar the volume
you can see here
3,90 someone is bidding the market here
right that's what's causing you to have
a Delta ofus 985 is because you have a
strong bidder in here so all that
aggressive selling that's taking place
at 08 is being absorbed by a strong
buyer okay just like you know over here
right you see 2851 all that aggressive
selling that's taking place at 03 is
being absorbed by a strong passive buyer
that that's what's causing you to have
this minus
977 in there is someone is stepping up
to the plate and saying hey you know
what not on my watch this Market's not
going to go lower and it's one thing you
know if you're looking at a footprint
chart to to see this it's more of an
advanced thing but what we have is a
tool on our orderflows Trader
software it's a setting that's called
price action Divergence right I don't
want to call it Delta Divergence because
that's we have that for something else
but here price action
Divergence uh we just going to enable it
here and it's going to show you on your
screen where it is taking place you see
right here right here right here green
is bullish red is bearish okay you know
go back to previous day's
session well nothing really standing out
there but I can see there was some
shooting out
from this day what day was it this the
30th right you can just see all this
price action negative price action
Divergence taking place right here a
little bullish one a little bullish one
then bearish bearish you know as this
Market drops from
18 almost down toble o gets down to you
know 01 before you get a look before it
starts going sideways and you know just
look at today today is uh what's say
Wednesday this holidays really got me
all screwed up literally right before
that big pop up on the jolts number you
had it right here ear in the day around
7 you had a couple backto back price
action
divergences and again you know if you're
more advanced orderflow Trader that
you're able to sort of spot these things
with your eye great but you know that's
why we create the orderflows
Traders is to help Traders understand
that you know what's taking place you
know I mean that's the bonds and again
this is a this is a five minute chart
you know honestly I also look at Bonds
on a four range chart it doesn't doesn't
matter if you use a four range chart a
five range chart or you know whatever
range
chart really what you want the type of
chart you want to look at is one that's
going to help you understand what you're
looking at in the order flow okay and
you can see here this was around 716 you
got the bearish one these are stacked
buying and balances which showing up
here here here again some smaller ones
there go back to you know yesterday on
this move up again it came in a little
bit earlier here here you around the
123 22 area and you see you know that
that's a full almost a whole point move
right here in the bonds then even along
the way you're getting some more
confirmation one and this goes back to
what I was talking about you know sort
of a regular Divergence and a hidden
Divergence when you see these in Trends
you know it could help you know give it
some think of it as as adding like
lighter fluid to to a fire you know
you've already got a lot of bullish
information taking place on this move up
and then you see that Divergence come in
you know you know that this move has
just got it's it's Rocket Fuel because
why because what you're seeing is you're
seeing strong bidding coming into this
Market I mean look at this bar right
here you know people are going to say
well it's got negative Delta minus 1801
this Market you know strong sellers
Market should come off but it doesn't
that's word catapults from and if you're
looking at the actual volume that's
taking place 4,000 on the bid 35,000 on
the bid bid the heaviest volume on the
offer side is just
2,800 you know if you're looking at a
market like uh Yen you know Yen I think
is is it's a nice Market to trade now
after uh you know it sort
of found its uh you want to call it you
know ever since a couple weeks ago with
what happened in in Japanese markets um
the Yen's been having nice moves and
again you know this is a range based
chart a four range um you know whether
using in a four range or
even um you know in eight range doesn't
really matter you know if you want to go
on a f minute
chart yeah you get some nice signals
there I know a lot of people always ask
me hey can I use you know order flow on
on a five range CH on a f minute chart
or 15-minute chart would I recommend
yeah you could use order flow on those
types of charts now there's certain
things in the orderflow that you could
use and the uh price action Divergence
tool is is one of them I mean it's giv
you buy buy buy little sell then another
buy right again this is a 5 minute chart
so I don't know if you'd want to put on
a position right ahead of a the jolts
number but if you know you
did did give you that but I'm not going
to claim that as a as a great trading
opportunity because I don't necessarily
recommend uh Traders jump in front of a
number like that but you can see here
the day before Lally right off the swing
low you got this nice move move
up okay nice move down so that is um you
know the Delta anomaly that we call
Price action Divergence okay it's a tool
that exists on the orderflows trader
software all right to help you
understand what you're looking at in the
footprint right because again you know
there's a lot of information in the
footprint right the footprint is just
data right it's up to you to analyze
that data and that's what the orderflows
trader does is it helps you analyze
um that data because there's no point in
looking at a footprint chart if if you
got no clue what you're looking
at
but fortunately we live in this computer
age where software can do a lot of the
heavy lifting for you so that's the
price action Divergence tool right just
to enable it you just click on it
boom all right everyone so thanks and
I'll catch you guys on the next video
bye-bye